Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the audience.
We do this via Discord.
You can find our discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
We are going to start today with Jess in Florida,
Jess in Florida.
Welcome.
Hello.
Hello, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Oh, hey.
Hi, David.
As you can hear me, OK, let's get into it.
So I have a question.
A couple questions regarding research literacy.
OK.
I think that as people, as Americans, we would
probably have an easier time solving problems
if we all had a sort of like foundation on
what the problems are.
Right?
Speaker 1: And also not only that, if we could
have an agreement as to what's a fact and
what's an opinion?
Speaker 3: Exactly.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
And you know, I had other questions regarding
like holy text and what that has to do with
it.
But getting to the point here, I was wondering
what what your thoughts are on on, you know,
creating research literacy classes in grade
schools to sort of help this on a long term
scale.
How would we do that?
Like what could that potentially look like
and what can people, listeners of yours who
aren't teachers or politicians do to help
enact something like that?
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
So first and foremost, the answer is yes.
I've never used the term research literacy,
but I've talked about bringing epistemology,
critical thinking and media literacy into
every classroom starting in, I would say,
at the latest in fifth grade.
Now how do we do it?
How do we do it?
The difficulty is it's basically determined
at the state level, right curricula determined
at the state level, overlapping with municipalities
underseen by overseeing rather by individual
superintendents, etc.
So the way to do this is we need activist
going to school board meetings everywhere.
In order to request this, you've got to lobby
the state boards of education and local municipalities.
And I'm not saying go and behave the way the
anti-mask people behave at the school board
meetings, but we need a concerted effort to
say we need media literacy, critical thinking
and epistemology coursework.
How do we why do we believe the things we
believe, starting no later than fifth grade?
It's going to take a lot of local activism.
Speaker 3: Yeah, as as a younger person, I
graduated high school in 2016, and the only
time I ever got any sort of research training
was like, How do you use a library?
You know, I mean, we need to learn how to
like, figure out what's true and what's not
true on the internet.
That's so important.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Jess, you've said it beautifully.
Can I ask what part of Florida you're in?
Speaker 3: Gainesville obligatory go gators.
Speaker 1: That's a that's a pretty red area,
if I understand correctly.
Speaker 3: Yes, it is.
And I have to deal with it all
the time, but not for long because I'm moving
to Oregon, where people are mass beautiful.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
All right, Jeff, thank you so much for the
call.
Thanks so much for by David.
All right.
Just from Florida in Gainesville for now,
but not for long.